hey you guys flickers of fear time doing
another movie review
this is one this is really interesting
because i remember this is uh called a
ghost story and it came out in 2017
and it's from a24
so i remember there being kind of a lot
of critical buzz about this one like
back when it came out
and right around that time i was kind of
like oh i gotta put that on my list i
gotta you know i gotta see that because
it sounded kind of cool like the concept
of it and then i sort of forgot about it
and then
a couple weeks ago when i did my review
i think it i think it was i am the
pretty thing that lives in the house
and on the comments of that review one
of our listeners might have been tammy
now that i'm thinking about it said oh
you know you should watch a ghost story
from 2017. it's still on netflix and um
you know if you like i am the pretty
thing this is like right up your alley
so i was like oh yeah [ __ ] i've been
wanted to see that and i totally forgot
about it so i went to netflix and
watched it now this movie
this is like
okay so it's not
it's a24 so like i said if you're not
down with the whole a24 already elevated
or whatever you want to call it then
stay way the hell away because this is a
really really arty movie it's not really
even a horror movie it's kind of like a
paranormal
drama like existential crisis kind of
movie it is legitimately one of the
saddest movies that i've ever seen but
you really have to get on the vibe of
this movie or you're just gonna be like
[ __ ] this it's like you know what i mean
because i kind of feel like
this is a real divisive type of thing
where it's like if you don't like some
people are just gonna think it's like
really boring or it's really pretentious
or
something like that and i can see that
those are legitimate uh criticisms but
to be honest with you it's like if you
just kind of like sit and
just let this movie sort of work its
magic on you
it's legitimately it was just like so
haunting you know what i mean and it's
like and i'm still i watched it like
several days ago and i'm still like
thinking about it it's just really like
crawls under your skin like it takes a
long time
to get going you know and i'll kind of
get into that in a minute because
there's some scenes that i think when it
because i think it premiered at sundance
and then it played like at some
festivals and stuff it was a very very
limited theatrical release and i feel
like during some of the scenes like some
people are like oh my god and it was
like got up and walked out so i can see
that but
you really have to
just kind of let this one do what it's
gonna do you know what i mean and
i don't know it just really really
got to me i just you know what i mean it
just had some kind of like weird
emotional kind of i don't know it just
made me feel a certain kind of way i
feel like a lot of people that you know
i've read some other reviews of it and a
lot of people seem to have that it's
really really sad you know it's just a
really really sad movie
so this was directed by david lowry now
this was the movie that he made after i
guess he made the live action pete's
dragon for disney which i actually
hadn't seen because i'm man i used to
love the you know partially animated
pete's dragon from back in the 70s or
whenever the hell that came out but i
heard it was really good but i haven't
seen it so i can't comment but this was
a movie that he made for almost no money
and they just shot it like in a couple
of days like in this house that they
were going to demolish so they were
basically kind of like sure you can film
in this house for free
uh so yeah so it's a very very small
very very independent uh you know
production which i thought was really
cool especially for somebody that's you
know making movies for disney obviously
so kind of a mover and a shaker if you
want to call it that it still wants to
do these like really small intimate sort
of projects which i think is really
awesome
so
i guess the idea for this david lowry uh
said because he wrote he wrote this as
well
was he's like i got the idea he's like i
really really like the image of the
ghost like the old school like halloween
costume ghost was just like a sheep with
eye holes cut out and he's like and i
really like
i liked the idea of taking something
like that that was kind of like funny or
silly or childish or something and kind
of putting it in a context where it was
like a lot more serious so he had that
idea and then he said i had this other
idea because him and his wife i guess
were uh they had an argument about
wanting like i guess she wanted to move
back to texas and he didn't want to
because he'd become attached to wherever
they lived and so he kind of got to
thinking about people's attachments to
the places where they live and you know
kind of being stuck in one place so he
kind of fused these two uh images
together or these two ideas together and
came up with the idea for a ghost story
now
this is a movie that it's very very low
on dialogue there's hardly any dialogue
in it there's kind of one scene in the
middle that's kind of like almost like
an expository type of scene other than
that the dialogue is very very very
minimal so much like i am the pretty
thing
which is this is sort of comparable i
guess although that one was more
a straight-up horror like you know
creepy ghost story whereas this one is
more like a drama but with some
supernatural elements to it like
supernatural elements are in there to
sort of make statements about bigger
themes uh you know about loss and grief
and about time passing and people with
unfinished business like people who die
with unfinished business things of that
uh nature
so this is kind of like
for such a small movie it really has
just these big ideas going on so like i
said so some people might think it's
pretentious i did not find it
pretentious but
i can see how some people would and like
i said that's a completely legitimate
criticism if that's how you're coming at
it but i didn't find it pretentious at
all
so the setup is casey affleck and rooney
mara play a couple they're married or
boyfriend girlfriend doesn't really
matter um they are never named i think
in the credits they're just called c and
m um but it doesn't really matter what
their names are
so he's a musician
and she has some other kind of job like
you know outside of the house they live
in this house i guess there there's some
argument at the beginning like not big
screeching arguments or anything but
there's a lot of tension in the
relationship at the beginning of the
movie because um much like the real life
argument between david lyrae's wife uh
one of them wants to move from this
house and uh the husband really doesn't
want to because he's become very
attached to this place it has history
here blah blah blah so he doesn't want
to move but they're having like kind of
tension about uh moving
now
he finally decides to you know make his
wife girlfriend whoever happy and he's
like okay finally we can move like this
one particular night this same night
they're in bed sleeping and they hear
something out in the living room sounded
like something like fell onto the piano
keys and this piano um you find out
later has been in this house for like a
really long time and you know it kind of
has some significance but so it sounds
like something fell on the piano but
they go out and there's nothing there
and then after which there's kind of a
shot they you know they don't find
anything there's nobody in the house so
they get back in bed and then there's a
really long shot i think it's like two
or three minutes of them just kind of
like snuggling up in the bed and i think
like i said there's a lot of shots like
this in like the first quarter of the
movie which i think really tried a lot
of people's patience
but
the thing about it i think he was trying
to because i forgot to mention too but
this is also shot
in like uh that kind of square what is
it like a 1.33 to one uh aspect ratio so
it almost and with rounded edges so it
almost kind of looks like old-school
home movies
and it also kind of like it's not shot
like that but just that aspect ratio
gives it that sort of vibe
and it's also kind of like much like uh
robert eggers did with the lighthouse
where it just seemed like um he was
trying to convey like a sense of like
confinement or being like trapped in a
box uh type of thing because that's
again another theme of this movie but
yeah that and the whole home movie thing
like really kind of gives it
it almost kind of gives it a vibe as
you're like watching it like it like
it's someone's home movies that you're
like just stumbled across that you're
not like supposed to be watching even
though like i said it's not you know
it's not like aged or not supposed to
look like a home movie or found footage
or anything like that but that aspect
ratio like gives it that kind of vibe
which gives it another
sort of layer i guess so yeah so there's
this really big long shot of them just
like kind of laying and cuddling in bed
together like i said i think it's about
two or three minutes which like i said
it doesn't sound like a long time but in
filmmaking terms that's a very very long
time to like hold a shot
but there are some shots like this in
the movie but i think what he's trying
to convey is almost kind of like someone
is always watching them so it's almost
kind of like gives a vibe of somebody
just always constantly watching them and
like i said it will come back around
where it turns out that someone is kind
of watching them so you know so there's
that kind of whole thing too so the
morning after this incident the husband
c
is killed in a car accident
now there's a scene where
the wife em she goes to like identify
his bodies at the morgue or whatever and
uh you know she spends a few silent
moments with him and then she covers him
up with a sheet now there's a very long
shot of
you know the body laying there under the
sheet and then after a really long time
like the uh he sits up
so he's just kind of under the sheet and
he's going through the halls of the
hospital
and no one sees him she's a ghost now
but like i said he looks like a
traditional like halloween type ghost
with like he's just wearing a sheet with
black holes for eyes so he goes down the
hall of the hospital and like this
kind of lighted door like opens up in
the wall which you're assuming is
supposed to be like heaven or the
afterlife or whatever and he kind of
looks at it but he doesn't go he turns
and like keeps going on through the
hospital so the door closes back up
and at this point the ghost like c is
now a ghost and he goes back to the
house that he shared with his wife and
basically just kind of stays there so
he's essentially watching his wife
go through the process of grieving him
and again probably the most infamous
notorious i don't know what kind of
thing i want to call it but the scene in
this that a lot of people walked out on
there is a legitimately five minute long
scene
of rooney mara
sitting on her kitchen floor crying and
eating an entire pie okay so i'm just
while the ghost like watches her because
she doesn't see him obviously but he's
like standing there watching her and
it's legitimately five minutes long so
like i said if that's good but
there it's in there for a reason it's
almost kind of like
i saw kind of this one breakdown of it
where somebody's saying you you know the
ghost is on the other side and then
she's kind of here in the foreground but
you're kind of the same distance away
from her as the ghost is so the ghost is
watching her from this side and you're
watching her from this side you're
basically just watching her go through
this grieving process and like i said i
think there's kind of a whole thing too
about
the meaning of life like is life
meaningful is it meaningless you know is
the only meaning like the meaning that
we give it and things like that so
little moments like this of just her
sitting on the floor for five minutes
like eating a pie was like not dripping
out of her nose it's just kind of like
that's it's almost kind of like making
you sit through like the grieving
process with her even though it's only
like five minutes long so after this
point i guess like from his point of
view from the ghost's point of view time
starts to move kind of like faster so
you know she gets over the grieving
process she ends up moving out of the
house
and then so the house is empty for a
little while then another family moves
in and they uh they don't speak english
it's it's a single mother and her two
kids and they just speak spanish and
actually i had the um the closed
captioning on because i'm deficient
so i put it on for every movie but they
didn't they actually didn't uh close
caption the spanish because i think they
wanted to show
that he's in this he's like remaining in
this house and now his wife is gone and
now there's his family and he doesn't
know who they are and he can't
understand anything that they're saying
so it's kind of like this whole thing
where it's kind of he's it's just more
isolating for him and also it's
interesting too because one time he
looks out the window of his house and
there is another comparable ghost in the
house next door and they kind of like
wave to each other and like they speak
telepathically which i thought was like
super funny
i don't know i just thought that was
really fun like a nice little subtle
humor in there like that the closed
captioning says no audio telepathically
and then it says then he's like hi how
are you and then like the other ghost is
like i'm waiting for someone you know i
thought maybe you know it's just like
this kind of sad thing so it's like
these ghosts and they're just like stuck
in these houses just like waiting for
you know the living people that they
love to come back i guess is like i said
so that's kind of the sad thing so at
some point with this family in here the
kids seem to they don't see him but they
kind of like sense that he's in the
house and it's kind of freaking him out
and so at one point he gets so angry and
frustrated that he starts doing like
poltergeisty [ __ ] like big time like he
just like starts throwing dishes around
and everything like that at which point
this family's like yeah [ __ ] this we're
out uh and they move out and then after
that there's another um i don't they
don't really go into like oh more people
moved in but there's like a house party
so there's like a whole bunch of people
they're kind of like hipster type people
and at this point there's a scene where
there's this one guy and it's just like
this really long scene that's five
minutes eight minutes something like
that and he just has this really long
kind of existential thing about do
people's lives have meaning because
everything you create
is just going to be like destroyed and
it's like even if it's not destroyed
he's like you know even like you know
beethoven's night
symphony which people still remember
like hundreds of years later but he's
like you know you know even if people do
remember something that you did like a
book that you wrote or a song that you
wrote or something like that um you know
eventually the universe is gonna die
there's gonna be like you know the big
crunch everything's gonna come down into
a singularity and stuff like that so
does it really
matter
so it's just kind of like this funny
he's very like mansplaining and stuff
and i think it's like really funny
because he's kind of talking about he's
not really saying that there's not an
afterlife but he's just saying that kind
of everything is meaningless and
meanwhile there's unbeknownst to
everybody there's like an actual ghost
like sitting over there like listening
to it which i think is really funny
so then it goes on even more where so
the house at this point like i said they
don't really say like how long it goes
because he's a ghost and you know it
doesn't um
time doesn't work the same for him so
he's still in the house the house is uh
you know derelict now there's nobody in
it it's all falling apart and everything
like that and he's still kind of there
and i forgot to mention too that one of
the things they kind of established this
at the very beginning of the movie
but his wife once said that everywhere
that she'd ever lived what she would she
had a habit of she would like write
something on a little note like to
herself um you know she's like it was
usually as part of a poem or a little
verse or something like that and she
would fold it up and she would hide it
somewhere in the house so like no one
would find it so that she would always
know it was there like just in case i
ever came back and there'd be like that
little piece of me that was left there
so she actually did that before she left
this house like after her husband died
so the ghost has been in the house like
trying to get this little piece of paper
like out of the wall because she like
stuck it like in the wall and like kind
of painted over it so it's kind of like
a [ __ ] for him to
get it out so he's kind of like been
picking around at it for however long
because like i said it's long enough
that the house you know went through a
couple families living in it and then
became completely derelict so it's
obviously been several years so he's
trying to pick it out and then all of a
sudden like you know the house gets torn
out like a bulldozer comes through and
tears the house down and uh so he's just
kind of stuck like standing there in the
middle of this rubble at which point he
looks over at the other ghost that's
next door and that house is also rubble
and the other ghost finally says i guess
they're not coming back and then poof
like the the sheet stays there but
whatever was underneath like animating
the sheet has disappeared so you're led
to assume that the ghost was waiting for
somebody they never showed up they
finally realized that you know this
person's never gonna so they decided to
move on but see uh the ghost just he
doesn't want to do that um because i
guess he's still got some unfinished
business
so
he basically just stays in this one area
and like a really long time goes by
there's like where the house was then
now there's um there's all this
construction and then there's like this
huge office building and he's like
walking through the office building and
then he decides he's going to jump off
the office building
and he does that but then when he jumps
off the office building i guess thinking
he's going to kill himself even though
he's already dead
he ends up
way back in time to where like these
settlers come and kind of they're like
this is where we're gonna build the
house you know what i mean so this
settler family comes where his old house
was and uh you know it's hundreds of
years in the past they get killed by
native americans there's like this whole
thing and so it's almost kind of like
he's
going through this humongous like time
loop because there's like another thing
like i said there's another thing um
with what the philosopher guy said at
the party about you know big bang big
crunch and everything
you know compressing down to a
singularity and then going back out
again so it's almost like a cyclical
type of thing you know so he's been on
this land all this time and then he gets
to a point where he's back at the start
of the movie so he sees himself alive
again and he sees his wife again and
they're in the house and so he's just
like going through this whole cycle like
over again
and uh and then it's weird too because
there's like another layer because now
there's like another ghost of him but
they don't see each other so it's just
kind of like this whole [ __ ] thing
and then at the end um finally he gets
that uh that piece of paper
out of the wall that like his wife put
in there and opens it and um he just
reads it like that and then he decides
he's going to move on and he poofs and
disappears they never do show you what's
on the paper i guess it doesn't really
matter
but that was kind of like what his
unfinished business was so
this movie this is one of the one like i
said this is one of the saddest
and strangest
movies but there's just there was just
something about it like the
the cinematography is gorgeous i love i
think a lot of people kind of snickered
at first because they're just like oh
it's a ghost movie but he's like
wearing an actual sheet like you know
what i mean but i don't know to me it
didn't seem that funny it seemed kind of
creepy you know i mean so it's like so
it wasn't like oh goofy it wasn't like
that it's like i thought it was kind of
like really effective
so just him
walking through these vast landscapes
and just the loneliness that you can and
obviously like you know the actor that's
underneath it sometimes it's casey
affleck sometimes it's uh you know
somebody else so just kind of like the
stillness and like the fact of his just
like walking through these vast
landscapes or just like standing in the
rubble of his old house and just
it just everything felt so lonely
because it's like there was you know
there was no way he could connect with
anything he was just like standing there
you know stuck just like the aspect
ratio uh you know suggested and he
couldn't move on because he felt like he
had something left to do or left to say
and he just so he's just there for like
eons and eons and just like living the
same time loop over and over again and
being completely unable to like finish
what it was that he was doing and it was
just there was just something really
really sad about it so if that sounds
like something that sounds like you're
because like i said it's not a horror
movie i don't want to say that
you have to be really really patient
with it it's a beautiful looking movie
like the cinematography is gorgeous it's
a very measured it's very deliberate
it's very still there's a lot of silence
there's a lot of really really long
shots of various things but
in a way it almost kind of like so but
if you get through that which is like
the first quarter of the movie it almost
has like this really eerie like hypnotic
kind of power to it because it really
does make you think about you know the
meaning of your life it's like in the
grand scheme of things in the in the
weirdest way and it's just so strange
that
a movie this
small and this intimate of this small of
a budget
could tackle these huge ideas which is
these very simple
visuals and just very simple idea of
just like a dude and a sheet and just
the fact that they used that but it
really kind of made you feel i don't
know man it just it made you feel like
just the passage of eons you know what i
mean and like your place and like this
vast history of the universe and stuff
like that and it's crazy
that this tiny movie about a dude in a
sheet like can make you feel like that
but like i said it's the more i think
about it the more brilliant i think that
it is because i think at first
and you know you guys know me i was like
i'm real into like i like slow burns it
doesn't bother me i'm not impatient or
nothing like that but i will say like
the first quarter of this one i was kind
of like it was it was getting to the
point where maybe was going to try my
patience a little bit
but then it really kind of
it i don't want to say like it picked up
necessarily but it just got more and
more like interesting
and
then after it was over like it just
really put me in this like really weird
kind of headspace
and like i said i watched it several
days ago and i'm still kind of thinking
about it so
i mean to me that seems like that's the
mark of like a pretty brilliant movie if
you're still even if the first time you
saw it you were just like oh i don't
know how i feel about this but then like
days later you just can't stop thinking
about it so that's like one of those
kind of movies so if that sounds like
something like i said a24 i don't think
i've ever seen a bad movie put out by
a24 they're always worth watching
and this one is definitely worth
watching but only if
you're kind of
gonna give it sort of your undivided
attention if you're just kind of gonna
let it take you on a journey i guess if
like i said it's not a horror movie it's
not there's no action there's no there's
very little dialogue it's mostly just
like a beautiful visual
poetic sort of meditative type of movie
so if that sounds like something that
you would like and you haven't seen it
yet then i would definitely recommend it
and tell me what you thought about it
it's on netflix still as of this
recording so go check it out and uh tell
me what you thought about it down in the
comments and i will see you guys on the
next flickers of fear see you later